[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the squad ride live
in the bleacher report app the most
important decision you're gonna make
today other than setting your fantasy
football lineup
is helping us to decide our week two
squad ride bet
we asked you on social who is a lot to
score a touchdown
thank you for last week by the way
because we won and big props to
chick spot picks by chicks excuse me
tiff uh for the
christian mccaffrey squad ride bet we
locked that in and we won
we have some great selections this week
and have picked three
of our favorite pitches to feature on
the show
to help you we have the big bank betting
expert kelly stewart and the babyface
assassin
recently getting quoted by chance the
rapper greg ivory is here
to help you with some hot takes my name
is cabbie richards
but the squad's fate is ultimately in
your hands
whatever you decide we're gonna bet as a
family and today we're betting big so
please
choose wisely um as an added bonus our
friends at draftkings
are going to boost the odds so place a
place a bet with draftkings and as soon
as the show's over
sign up today if you don't have an
account uh listen if you tried last week
there was an issue uh we're aware that
some of the users may not have gotten
their
bleacher report christian mccaffrey
sorry bleach report
odds boost from draftkings on the
christian mccaffrey to score touchdown
prop bet um draftkings has identified
those users and
issued credits so we apologize again for
that little mix-up
all right let's roll into uh week two
get in the comments
fire off your hot takes we want some
great pics
good vibes only and as mikey locks
always says let's get rich
uh always in a giving mood we're gonna
give away some exclusive bleacher report
betting hoodies
you know we love them we love giving
them to you uh and in fact we're gonna
start the show with some
good juju some good vibes so we're gonna
give away a hoodie right now
g-money greg ivory is in the comments
who are you gonna give a hoodie away to
my jabs you know i'm in the comments and
i'm searching
and i see my guy captain rodriguez 24.
he says devonta
adams a lock for a touchdown
that's a that's a good one that's a good
one before we hear
our first pitches uh here are some of
our favorite takes and moments from last
week
my lock of the week of touchdown scorer
is saints running back alvin kamara
gotta be derek henry versus the jags got
to be derek henry
allen robinson will score a touchdown
this week
she'll lock it in it's locked it's going
to be in the end zone he's my pick of
the week
[Music]
gabby i gotta go buy a new fridge i'm
clearly missing out on life
that was it oh my gosh that was pure joy
i love that
kelly i know you i know you got a fridge
uh that has a tv
no i gotta i'm gonna make a trip right
now to the appliance store i gotta get a
new one that is absolutely awesome
okay so it's time for our first of three
pitches cooper norton
is gonna try to convince you to follow
his lead for our week two squad ride
drop your reactions in the comments
cooper who you pitching
my pick of the week cam newton easy he's
going to the pylon
every time he's at the 5 yard line they
gave it to him twice last
last week they have absolutely trusted
him he's not handing off to sony
michelle he's going
every single time let's go touchdown
easy
rushing let's go be our betting baby
let's go let's go
my guy cooper with the lock right i mean
i'm loving that
cabbie like i'm sorry to cut you off but
i was just so
interested in this bet being plus 220
camp newton to score a touchdown i mean
he just ran the ball 15 times last week
he scored two touchdowns last week plus
220 i'm
loving this value i can see cam newton
in the end zone kelly what's what's the
line about
uh white claws oh cabbie ain't no laws
when you're drinking claws
our dude cooper had a few claws leave
him alone he's just living his best life
he really is did that land for you kels
his pitch
you know it's not that it didn't land
for me cabbie i've been a big proponent
of
cam newton all year i do think he's
going to excel
bill belichick knows cam strengths and
weaknesses and that is
running the ball my problem here is the
seattle defense especially at home
they were absolutely locked down against
the falcons last week
and they were able to shut down todd
gurley in that rushing game
i'm a little nervous with this one wait
kelly you just mentioned
the seahawks at home you understand that
there's no fans right
there is no fans they're gonna pump in
fake noise though and and
you have to remember greg this is still
an east coast team traveling west there
is still somewhat of a little bit of a
home field advantage here
i played the seahawks full disclosure i
laid the four
so that makes it really difficult for me
to want to back
a patriots play uh player prop gotcha
gotcha got it got it there are no fans
but there is a safety name jamal adams
on that seattle defense so that'll
somewhat something to worry about for
cam newton uh g-money you are paying
attention to the comments
hey you're reading them all you see my
my my eyes are
glued to the comments because i'm tapped
in with everybody
actually i mean come talk to us on
youtube we're in the youtube comments
right now so if you're not in the
youtube comments this is where it's at
i'm giving away hoodies
in the youtube comments and i see my guy
uh
hunter ham he said that you were landing
kelly
so since he said you were landing i'm
gonna give him a hoodie
well-earned hunter nice job okay so last
week
um i feel like giving away another
hoodie to our commenters in youtube and
eventually in the uh yeah
youtube um last week um cam newton
rocked a canary it was a
beautiful canary yellow suit had the red
like poppy lapel pin
his accessory game is always on point um
he's a fashionista in the nfl so we're
going to give away another hoodie
this is simple it's an over under
question the question is
does cam newton have over or under 3
million followers
on the gram just answer with over or
under
in the comments does he have over under
3 million followers on instagram
greg's gonna give somebody a hoodie just
in a little bit not right now
uh let's get to our our next pitches
so our next pitch we're asking you guys
to help us decide
our week two squad ride bet uh so drop
your takes in the comments and as a
bonus
our friends at draftkings are gonna
boost the odds
so jack vitale what do you got for us my
dude
yo what up it's jack vitale my pick of
the week is zeke
i think that he's gonna really tee up on
uh
atlanta's defense they're terrible
absolutely terrible
and uh he scored two touchdowns last
week made me some money so
zeke's my pick i really think it'll
he'll make it happen
yo this guy said zeke made him some
money last week he definitely took that
money and bought that do-rag i see you
though i see i see
but let's talk about your bet i mean to
be honest
i'm on the cowboys bandwagon today i do
think that they're going to win today's
game so with that being said
i need zeke to score so i mean i like
your bet dude i like it zeke's getting
in
in the end zone i like it i like it all
right jack jack
mentioned that falcon defense we already
touched on it you guys don't need me to
bring it back up that falcons defense
is going to get ran all over today by
zeke
i don't know i'm a little nervous about
the cowboy zone now greg so they opened
a seven point favorite they have some
cluster injuries we've been all aware of
it now the line has moved
cowboys minus three you may be on to
something there
with a buy on spot here on the cowboys
if you have falcons
plus seven plus six and a half plus six
congratulations to you that's a great
number
i think i gotta go with jackie i think
he's right i think zeke
has to score if the cowboys want to win
this game
zeke's gonna need at least two
touchdowns kels you said you said a buy
on spot what exactly
what is that exactly so at a certain
point in time
we've spoke about all the last year and
a half that i've been with bleach report
you have
to play numbers not teams at
seven the line was too steep so you have
to look at a buy on spot
on the falcons at three we're talking a
four-point line move here
it may be over reaction and that's
probably why greg
likes the cowboys okay g-money how do
the
how does how do the commenters feel
about the zeke elliott
to score a touchdown prop cabbie i am in
the comments and i'm seeing
lots and lots of zeke will be
getting in the end zone today so the
fans are riding the fans are writing let
me give away a t-shirt my guy
a hoodie we're giving away hoodies my
brother oh yeah thank you for corre
i'm so sorry i'm giving away two hoodies
just for me saying that my guy
hugh james hugh james he's loving your
eyebrows kelly
i think
that lands that land so my guy hugh
james you're getting a hoodie
and also my guy hudson
hudson alice he's rocking with the over
over three million that on the um trivia
question
question yes he's rafael or he's got on
the ground okay just because of that
just because of that i'm gonna give him
a hoodie why not i mean he's trying you
know what i mean just for trying just
for trying
greg would give everybody hoodies if he
could he's such a i really would i
really would
and we appreciate you guys rocking with
us so two pictures and we heard cooper's
pitch
that cam noon will score a touchdown
today in seattle and we just heard
from jack vitale for ezekiel elliot to
score a touchdown
in it or versus atlanta keep dropping
your takes in the comments
we got hoodies to give away to the
homies so as g money mentioned earlier
we asked you
the trivia question cam noon does he
have
over or under three million followers on
instagram g money we we
there are a couple we you've selected a
couple of people someone picking the
over
someone picking the under yes tell us
who they are
yes cabbie so my guy kobe r
he took the over and my guy yvonne
sanchez took the under well the correct
answer is 4.8 million
followers on instagram so that's the
over
so g money who are we sending a hoodie
to we're sending the hoodie to my guy
colby kobe r we're sending you a hoodie
bro
uh tap in the dms hit me hit hit the
bleacher report betting
we're gonna uh get you a hoodie all
right listen but
if you if you didn't win one it's cool
don't worry we're gonna we have
many more hoodies to give away and we
have uh you know we have one more
over under question for you right now in
fact ezekiel elliott as jack vitale
i brought him up and we've been talking
about feed and zeke he signed a
record-setting
six-year contract in 2019.
the trivia question is is the value of
the contract
over or under 100 million dollars
get in the comments just tell us over or
under
100 million dollars we're gonna give
away a hoodie in just a little bit
but we have our third and final pitch of
the squad ride show
our dude dukan is gonna pitch you on a
player prop ducan who do you got for us
who do you like
rest easy with your money on juju this
week he put up two touchdowns last week
in week one
against the giants defense i think he's
gonna repeat and do it a second time two
touchdowns for juju
this week we got big ben back he's
healthy
he's gonna put the ball in a dime and
you got juju going up against
two smaller corners now defense
defensively the
broncos will throw a couple different
looks at you but they're smaller corners
i see juju getting the release and he's
gonna be tough to tackle out there
lock it in juju
i love that he said we there g-money did
that land or not
ah cavi i don't know i'm a little torn
but one thing i do know
if anyone is happy big ben is back it's
juju smith shuster
i mean um he he went six for 69 with two
touchdowns last week so he had a good
game
now this week they're facing this
broncos defense that has a secondary
that's
pretty good i don't know if i'm rocking
with juju getting in the end zone i
don't know i can see them uh
running the ball a little bit and uh i
don't know i just don't know i'm torn
i can't commit to this one you know
what's crazy greg i'm also in a
conundrum here look i got juju on my
fantasy team i'm a big juju fan and his
dog
boujee is like coco and vegas boyfriend
listen
i want juju to do well but i got a
broncos plus seven and a half ticket in
my pocket so
i'm with you here this was this is tough
i do think juju will get past
that young secondary this broncos
defense showed
signs last week of absolute utter
weakness without von miller i do think
the pass rush is still there
but dink and duncan to juju especially
in the red zone we know what's gonna
happen juju is probably gonna score a
touchdown
and uh props to dukan uh mentioning
denver's
secondary it's featuring two rookies uh
michael o.j moodia
and moody and uh isaiah bassey so
there's a good chance that juju will be
dancing dude on that beat
in the end zone uh against denver okay
so we have uh
the pitches are in greg what was your
favorite what was your favorite oh no we
started we're in the comments we're
getting it
hold on oh hold on hold on we are
getting mad love in the comments my guy
kevin saint gene i want to sing you five
hoodies for your comment
he said he's bloody you know listen he
said he loves the show
he's been watching cabbie on webinar and
and kelly is amazing and then he even
shouted me out
thank you brother you're getting the
hoodie now let me go let me hold on
kathy i'm giving i'm giving them i'm
giving away hoodies here
michael fushi michael fushi you're also
getting a hoodie
victor you're getting a hoodie uh what
are these guys saying that
that's making you be so generous this
morning cabbie it doesn't matter what
they're saying i'm just giving away
hoodies okay you know what i mean it's
it's
it's like christmas right now greg's in
the comments
what okay let's let's get you out of the
comments for a quick second because our
three pitches are in
we got uh cooper norton on cam newton to
score
a rushing score touchdown we have jack
vitale
uh on ezekiel elliott to score a
touchdown and we just heard from dukan
juju smith schuster to score a touchdown
versus the broncos today
the pitches are in greg which one was
your favorite pitch
ah cabbie you see that plus 22 on the
screen right there
220. plus plus 220 i'm sorry the plus
220 on the screen
i'm rocking with my guy cam and the new
england patriots
if the if they have the ball inside the
five
you know what you're gonna see you're
gonna get a heavy dose of cam
power right walking into the end zone
super manning cam
yes superman cam is gonna get in the end
zone i'm rocking with cam tonight
kelly which uh which one of those
pitches do you think deserves an
odds boost from our friends at
draftkings you know we have to go
with zeke here just like last week when
you're getting three to one
on one of the best running backs in the
league you absolutely take it
you guys gotta vote for zeke here well
last week we had christian mccaffrey who
was an elite running back this week
kelly likes ezekiel elliott as the elite
running back to get into the end zone
so uh you have all the information you
need now it's on you to decide
our week two squad ride bet drop drop
your picks in the comments
and whether it's cam it's zeke or juju
and
we're gonna get a an odds boost from our
friends at draftkings so while we tally
the squad ride bets uh we have another
hoodie to
give away earlier i asked you ezekiel
elliott
the value of ezekiel elliott's contract
all right so over under a hundred
million dollars as you get in the
comments
with an over or under greg has picked
two commenters someone is go is
on the over another person is on the
under
g money who are these commenters i mean
okay here we go cabbie on the over we
got my guy
jacob e rocking with the over on the
under we got my guy
stealth freak 25
stealth freak 45 yeah i had to slow that
one down i had to make sure i got it
right you know what i mean
stealth freak 25 i kind of want to know
how that person arrived
at that handle but that's for another
show i imagine and we probably can't
get into it here okay so the answer is
the answer is it is under
zeke elliott's deal was for 90 million
dollars so who are we giving
a hoodie to stealth freak 25 my guys
stealth
freak 25 you're getting a hoodie bro
excellent uh well it was you you earned
it my friend all right so stick with the
show we have many more
hoodies to give away and you'll get
another chance to win one
same time same place next week here in
the bleacher report app
all right so it's time for the big
reveal our squad ride bet
the votes have been tallied in week two
the winning pitch is
ezekiel elliott oh i heard it yes
ezekiel is right there at -265 and thank
you to our friends from draftkings we're
gonna boost that
to plus 300 i guess they were listening
to you kel's we're boosting that to
three to one odds for ezekiel elliott to
score a touchdown
that's gonna be an interest that's gonna
be a fun game to watch against atlanta
tonight or to atlanta today
all right so uh if you need some more
action like you always do
listen last year our mvp went 12-5 on
her best bets
last week she gave us the new orleans
saints
as her best bet and alvin kamara came
through with two touchdowns
so thank you for being off to a great
start one in o'kell's
this is your time kelly stewart give the
people your best bet
let's go all right guys we're going to
rock with the eagles today now
i know that the line has moved
significantly but i'm not concerned
about it very rarely do nfl games land
one now if
it does land one i don't want to hear
about in the dms
i gave this out a plus one on wednesday
and i'm giving it out
this morning philadelphia moneyline
minus 125
is probably the better price than laying
one and a half so shop around make sure
you guys
get the best of the number here now look
the big narrative
all week long is the eagles are banged
up they led 17 to nothing over the
football team last week and then
lost on the road they're now back at
home also
lane johnson carson wentz's security
blanket on the o-line is back
he plays so much better when that dude
is in the lineup
and last but not least this is the
biggest overreaction of the week
the 12-day number that's right the
number that comes out prior
to the week one games being played was
eagles minus four what did we see
happen in the last two weeks well
the eagles blew a 17-0 lead to the
football team and the rams squeaked out
a win at home
over the dallas cowboys do not buy into
the hype the eagles are going to win
this game and hopefully it's as easy as
last week
with the saints over the box we have to
protect kelly stewart at all costs
they got to protect carson wentz please
wrap my dude in bubble wrap cabbie we
need carson wentz not to be sacked eight
times this week if we want to win this
game
we are riding with kelly let's go let's
go
let's go eagles get in your abs get
those wagers in if you're rocking with
our mvp
kelly stewart congrats swallow winners
thank you to all our commenters
big shout out to cooper norton dukan and
jack vitale
for your submissions this week send us
videos of your wait have you cabbie wait
wait wait before we
before let me get some work i'm getting
mad love in the comments we're
we're all getting mad up i just got to
give away some more hoodies my guys chad
butcher jab butcher future i don't chat
yeah whatever
he said kelly's best bet he needs your
best bet i like it because i'm
riding we got my guy max levingston
you're getting a hoodie brother we got
my guy eric morales riding with the
eagles i'm giving you a hoodie cabbie
this is the last one i promise
i promise is the last one my guy uh
you know what i'm done
[Laughter]
g-money had like 30 hoodies he's like
how many have i given away i've given
away all
30 okay i'm done so thank you to
everybody
um great that's okay
gotta keep them on their toes kelly same
time same place
more hoodies to give away we know that
g-money is enthusiastic with
his generosity so there will be ample
time for you guys to win hoodies
thank you for riding with us alongside
kelly stewart greg ivory
my name is cabbie richards enjoy your
football sunday and good luck with your
bets
[Music]
peace
[Music]
you